so it's like
it's like honestly I like I saw this guy
you're like Michael cheated on me when
he was in a beef heart and I was like
because he was telling me he's like you
know no I miss you or whatever and I'm
not
I don't miss me what am I your mother
[Applause]
got him you do a British accent don't
you
I've been working on it
but my friends and colleagues don't
think it's very good
keep the sentences short it was very
good at the beginning
and Hathaway Mistress of the accent yes
can you do Cockney go on and give it a
go babe
all right love you want me to give it a
go
we were talking with uh Antonio Salma
about you know their difficulties with
English when they got to America sure
but in this tour this is good and you do
a kind of Master Class in accents well I
was trying to get better I've been doing
like I've been a stand-up comedian for
like 10 years and I was trying to get
better at it I thought what can I get
better at and it's accents so I've gone
away discovered the secret of doing like
good Regional accents is you need a key
phrase to get you started if you're
doing the accent once you get that key
phrase in your head then you get started
I could teach you like smacks I can't do
yours I could do ones from around
Britain I could do to be useful you see
Victoria then you could start playing
British people and you know sure Meryl
Streep gets them all now and you know
you could be in Desperate scouse wives
so under scale Saxon so if you want to
talk like someone from Liverpool you say
this this phrase you say awesome chicken
you've got to try it okay YouTube okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
you sounded like you were trying to be a
ventriloquist there because then once
you say it then you can say something
properly authentically Scouts like you
said I want some chicken I'm going on
the Rob
I've got to get a Prezi it's my Grand's
birthday she's 30.
story and I think it's a cockney accent
I'm not sure when we were filming Batman
there's this one day we were filming in
central London and Christian was walking
to set and they're these two boys and
they're sitting there and they're
staring at him and one of them goes oi
you Batman
and the other one goes no he's not
Batman look at his teeth
whatever that means I just thought if
could our American Stars you know do a
cotton accent so these are Cockney
Expressions East End Expressions but
written phonetically okay so you'll get
it as we go along so Debbie if you want
to read if you want to be on the screen
all right so if you read this
phonetically it you should sound like a
sender if you get them they're good okay
this is very good too let's try this one
try this one Jamie you've got is there
any cockneys in the house it's got we've
got that yeah can you use it in a
sentence well yeah yeah you could so but
try to sign up quarter Panda there you
go see quarter
it's like you live in the East end it's
like you're in Walford Believers
Believers we have a message from your
leader
I love you
hey what about hey wait wait hello how
are you you like my English accent
it's very nice very well thank you
Cheerio
[Applause]
so I like I like British accents because
they're so sexy
[Applause]
how much is it it's about champ and 50.
[Applause]
Long Beach how much is it
one last one for Usher what have you got
for us we're so much here oh this
I mean
[Applause]
I mean do you know what I mean yeah
very good we have to mention uh
Braveheart whatever it is for
everybody's favorite spot
how hard was that for you it was
difficult but I was up there and
immersed among people who all needed
subtitles
what are you saying they'd have to
repeat it So eventually it kind of
worked its way into my lexicon and
he helped you
at dinner one night he did and he used
we were having we were at Andy vanya's
place and he's Hungarian and he made
goulash now imagine Sean Connery saying
that word
he said I always have great rules with
my goulash
fantastic
so I never forgotten it
makes you just want to say it right it's
good yeah teach another accent from the
UK
roller coaster pooper scooper Oompa
Loompa Kawasaki 4 unrelated words but if
you want to do the Geordie accent how
people talk from Newcastle those words
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Graham Norton here if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that then hit
subscribe
or don't it's a free world but I know
what I do in that situation